I think a lot of people are surprised to
the fact that I like to have like a
stuffed animal and sleepy stuffed animal
but they end up being like Oh I need to
do that I should probably do that hey GQ
what's up I'm Tanner Buchanan and these
are some of my essentials
[Music]
First Essential is my Kali sticks I
picked this up season five of Cobra Kai
Kali is the national martial arts of the
Philippines my mom's half Filipino my
grandpa was full Filipino my mom was a
secondary degree black belt and then
obviously with the show we do Taekwondo
Muay Thai now we're doing weapons I had
a different set of Kali sticks now I've
kind of upgraded to these heavier
versions and these really really hurt
when you hit yourself so you don't want
to do it but I try my best it makes me
better I guess all right
this is my first like nice acoustic
guitar this one literally travels with
me everywhere like I don't go anywhere
without it this is a 2002 Taylor
presentation mother of pearl inlay all
the way up the neck this one to me is
one of a kind just the action on this
guitar is unlike any other guitar that
I've ever played so I also did a show
called designated Survivor and I brought
it to Kiefer Sutherland who obviously
sings and has his own band and he played
this guitar and he's like what did you
do to this guitar I was like I don't
know I just picked it up and it just it
played this way it sounded this way
whoever had this guitar before me set it
up so nice
thing is Speed Cube I am very nerdy and
kind of got into speed cubing when I was
about
12 I did a very deep rabbit hole and
watch cubing videos follow the
competitions try to learn all the
different algorithms when I was
practicing all the time I believe I got
down to 30 seconds I don't know if I
really
solve it as much it's more become like a
fidget toy Ashley was trying to solve it
this morning with all the jet lag and
everything my mind is not working and I
was like that's not nope that's not
right well we got this corner in I don't
know how we did it but it was an
accident so we're gonna count that one
and I'll finish this in a little bit
next I have my 35 millimeter film camera
[Music]
I did a movie called he's all that where
the character was interested in
photography and I thought the best way
to kind of do that was to buy myself a
film camera and kind of see what I could
do with it and I actually just fell in
love with it you just need to go out
shoot and find your own style the
opportunity to kind of see the world in
just a different lens and makes me kind
of stop and look the world in a
different way
this is a teddy bear given to me by
someone very special I basically will
travel everywhere with this there's
multiple times that I've had very
important things in my carry-on suitcase
and the bear doesn't fit and I will take
way more important things out of the bag
to fit this bear and it's actually you
can heat it up in like the microwave
because it's like a heating pad too I
have a lot of different like stuffed
animals and stuff that yeah I've had
since I've been a kid my next essential
jewelry
I was never into jewelry until I did a
role in a play I was talking with the
director and he basically thought oh I
think the character should have jewelry
because he's like a teenager and angst
yeah I was like yeah sure whatever my
parents got me this ring for my opening
night basically started the whole
collection of rings that I do have my
second ring was actually this one it's
from Florence Italy and it's from one of
the oldest Jewelers from Florence and
they are a family business this one I
wear all the time this is from a place
called The Great frog obviously a lot of
like rock stars and stuff we have the
big chunky Rings if you want a ring for
some reason that's where they go I ride
motorcycles and I always looked up at
people that were like riding motorcycles
and they had the big rings and they're
like super badass and I was like bad
then I have this snake one of my
castmates gave it to me it's obviously
Cobra Kai snake it doesn't fit on any
other finger other than my ring finger
so I have to double it up with the wolf
because I don't really want to put a
ring on my on my marriage finger not yet
this is also a ring that I got very
recently but I wear all the time it came
from a fan and then finally we have this
necklace me and my castmates made charm
necklaces for each other I always make
sure that I I have this on because it
has a lot of meaning to me as well we
always got to have a portal speaker
well I guess for me I'm a Metalhead I
mean my all-time favorite metal band is
Pantera Dimebag is the best guitarist
that has ever left he actually died on
my birthday and I was I'm originally
from Ohio and he actually died in Ohio I
also really really love a band uh called
Gojira I love a band uh called Opeth
their lead singer I actually think has
one of the most heavenly voices there's
a band called cattle decapitation it's
too scary for a lot of people that I
introduced them to I scare a lot of
people because I'll turn my volume all
the way up and then I'll forget and then
I get in the car and then people get in
the car with me and I'll turn it on and
just like blares and everybody just
jumps I've practiced magic since I've
been about six or seven I was introduced
into Magic by my grandpa it's very
relaxing to me I just love to perform
the performance aspect and being able to
like bring that joy and kind of fool
people everybody sees magic and they
just you can't not love it oh let's see
oh messy but I did it these are my hair
products
I recently found out that I have curly
hair a lot of people don't realize that
they have curly hair these are like a
very natural silicone free they don't
have a lot of like additives in them
it's the most natural thing that you can
do for your hair specifically curly hair
and I'm sure there's a lot of people out
there because it's been going around
recently it's like the curly girl method
which I follow I know exactly how long
it takes me and take me just under an
hour 52 to 56 minutes hair has become a
super important thing to me and I can't
live without these I was uh in England
for about five weeks doing project and
they don't sell this brand there I
overnighted this to my parents house and
then made them overnight it to me to
England and last but not least coffee
I know these are coffee beans
it's just coffee I absolutely love
coffee I don't want anything in it I
just want just normal black coffee no
milk no sugar no anything I always have
to start my day off with coffee if I
don't start my day off with coffee then
my entire day is just screwed up coffee
is one of those Essentials to me that I
always have to have and it's the first
thing that I I look for anywhere I'm
going I try to find the nearest coffee
shop that's like a really nice like good
coffee shop but wherever I go that's
this is the thing that I need always
always always always always thanks for
watching GQ and these have been 10 of My
Essentials